sponsored by WB games welcome back to
inside Lego dimensions hi this is a show
sponsored by WB games in which I Chris
waters and me Aaron from game grumps go
through Lego dimensions to show you guys
a little bit about all the Lego magic
contained therein how exciting we kicked
it off with the starter pack episode and
now we're into the level packs and today
it's back to the future Oh Bob of butter
it's Marty white marsh Marty McFly and
he's guys good talk a little guitar
awesome Johnny be good dude put that
dude on the toy pad let's get this thing
rolling now he's in the game rock it out
look at that solo yeah uses his guitar
as in taxis like whoa all right level
select we are gonna go to the special
level that comes with the Back to the
Future level pack grow a hill valley
Hill Valley baby let's do it
so here's Marty McFly hanging out with
his best friend Batman yeah good friends
went to college together I used to use
the bowl the same lanes all the time you
know they live together for a semester
but uh Batman keeping those late hours
was really tough on me yeah I was kind
of kind of a hard time I'm just gonna
Batarang pretty much everything in your
house Marty how you feel about well it's
not my house is Doc's house so do ever
you want ah you can go ahead and thank
you for the hospitality doc what is this
was this situation for me oh I could
build the hoverboard oh nice all right
we are gonna build ourselves a little
hover board here using the magic of
television
boom Thank You Batman right oh heck yeah
anyone can read the hoverboard dude
Batman get on over board where to go
it's right underneath you were on it now
you're on it oh so the thing about the
hoverboard is you can like if you're
like up here say on this ledge up here
so if you like use the bed to like get
up to this top platform up here now oh
I'd knocked a ladder down for you so if
you bring the hoverboard up here you can
like hover across this platform and get
to the other one how do I jump in the
hoverboard so you can like I can like
Holly attack yeah you can you can get
off of it and then go up and then like
all the hoverboard folio you're certain
amount of time after you get off so yeah
it comes up and then you get on it and
then so now it's like I can get a crawl
hold on on you get off here yeah there
we go so we push this down outer board
knocks over the thing and then now we
got toast Wow giant human sized toast
hey get over here Marty we need a solo
or not yeah all right that's right come
on Marty Homer weird dude oh all right
yeah there we go I have a feeling this
is gonna go very well cool it's all back
together now I just got to go over there
with my sick guitar skills and let er
rip
oh he's just he's just straight-up he's
just straight-up dead well that's one
way to get out of a garage yeah well now
we transition into Twin Pines mall ah we
risk we first see doc and also there's
that famous car the DeLorean oh yes the
Orion mmm all right let's drive this
thing yeah I feel like I will take the
hoverboard so I gotta I gotta bust open
this this a bill and ted phone booth
right here using the power of rock yes
indeed indeedly doodly so what we want
to do is we want to build this device
that doc was working on that like lets
it go through time we got to make it the
thing that can take us back to the
future yes what you're saying exactly
because we have to go back exactly right
so but right now we can just like
collect some stuff cuz the only reason
the only way we can do it is with parts
from this these trash it's trash over
here these trash cans oh yeah Batman's
on the case I'm that grappling stuff if
you are you're going to that hoverboard
is like not letting you go it's my
friend is following me around buddy gosh
dog you are just such a friendly little
hollow board who wants to get ridden
these do it was throwing bananas at us
that would be the Libyans rude the keys
to look for these little benches that
have you know little lights searchlights
coming out from behind them cuz that's
how you know you're gonna get stuff you
can build out of the stuff that you
destroy I think this switch Marty I
switch yeah man I just built it check it
out Oh Batman pushing on the back smell
it even though she had a switch going oh
you know just beating up some benches
building switches that's how Batman do
nice nice oh yeah I got that DeLorean
what you driving it up in there huh yeah
dude reverse styles oh oh oh Jesus is
ruined everything oh god I'm so sorry Oh
Marty well fix it the only way you know
how to go up in here let's play some
teams yeah rock and roll
that's your special day yeah there we go
doc are you all right bustin everything
open all right we'll get on the build
case filled it every character in Lego
dimensions can build stuff they're all
very talented Lego heroes they are all
equally talented at building put this
stuff together mm-hmm I'll just play a
tune for you Oh little building tune
looks like we made a sick jump yeah well
actually it's the the device that'll
send us through time here we go I'm
going back in time dad their prayer I
man what y'all wrap up there you go
switch now we're 1955 there's cows here
yeah funny cows cows will ruled the
earth in 1955 obviously that was true
then as it is today how'd you get up
there man oh I see some stars we might
need to bring oh we got to bring the
g-man bring the g-man Gandalf judo yeah
so let's just comes out like whoa you
rang I'll sweet to some special stuff up
there isn't it shake it baby each level
pack level has these special
collectibles you can get so in this one
it's mr. fusion and in other level packs
it's themed around the level you know
around the the movie or the characters
that you have these purple bricks of
course represent like little tricks that
you can do with other characters this
one requires golem or somebody else and
you know there's a lot of sort of
overlapping intertwining stuff like that
that really make it like going back into
level packs and going into levels with
different characters get you more
unlockables gets you more Easter eggs
and just get you out get you more like a
fun times that's right son outside this
barn door lies more adventure for the
young Marty McFly and rock not just
playing solo shows for the amusement of
bovines but we're going to go check out
the adventure worlds now because there's
a whole lot more stuff you can explore
and unlock and just generally enjoy in
terms of a hold back to the future feel
inside the back to the future adventure
world let's check it out flying through
the Gateway at the speed of light that
did it that the tiptoe that's a mini
game on so avoid that spinning DeLorean
oh we are boom
Hill Valley baby in story mode you're
generally close to each other and but in
adventure mode you can go to totally
different places yes Batman dig in the
hoverboard yeah so there's there's all
kinds of collectibles and stuff in here
so your actions in the past when you
affect the add the stuff in the present
oh that's what's unique about this world
hey man it's back to the future what's
up Oh God oh no what happened I've
destroyed that person oh it's probably
fine I mean they're just Legos I guess
Oh meanwhile Batman has decided to
stealth infiltrate something over here
ooh it's good Oh what did you see you
they spotted Gandalf oh not getting dog
stop stop sneaking around Gandalf
everybody can see you come on Kendall
Audrey where's how'd you do a thing I'm
getting a gold brick whoa what is that
it's like a super good thing oh yeah
these are one of the things uh you know
there's a ton of them in the game well
quick grab it nice what about the bomb
yeah I got on my screen so um well we're
sharing sharesies oh sure yay you can
say that alright Batman hop on the
hoverboard and go ahead the gold brick
is just one of the many things that you
can grab in adventureland and you also
get gold bricks for completing levels in
story mode mmm and then there's red
bricks and then there's those special
items like we found earlier tons of
stuff to find hang well I'm wrecking the
shop that's what you doin eventually
just wreck everything wrecking stuff is
fun yeah I gotta say you are one of the
more fun things about with the lego
games oh wait reckon I need I need a
DeLorean DeLorean to me come to me
DeLorean where's I just lands on your
head on my head yep Oh the DeLorean Oh
quick I gotta chase this uh timer thing
it's got a red brick oh dang yeah wow
you got it mm-hmm I can drive a DeLorean
that was way better than I did at home
oh I think I'm gonna take us back to the
future again oh my god yeah oh yeah that
brings us to the the future my
the nation time 2015 is it going to
change your world too yeah so now we're
going to be in 1985 whole valley where
all the shops resurrect are still this
is the future the future future this is
2015 el valle so everything that we did
in a past affects the present isn't that
cool that's cool man I mean they're like
I also just like the futuristic touches
I got a little hovering car here coming
through oh yeah we'll have a car come
back here tell me your secrets I'm
mixing up the voices and also in this
world is a good place to get money to
buy all kinds of stuff they're like
inflation is high I go back in the past
you ready to go back in the past that
everything's super cheap you'd like to
buy things for a dime well this guy
wants me to like repair something that
lock the jukebox sure that's a lot the
jukebox whoa got the jukebox time to
juke it baby yeah play some music just a
lot of shenanigans to be had in Hill
Valley tons of shenanigans future
shenanigans past shenanigans talking
about all kinds of shenanigans dude tons
of stuff to do lots of unlockables
vehicle upgrades more levels to play
with all in the level pack featuring
back to the future thanks for watching
this episode of inside lego dimensions
you